that was the opening bell on the new
york stock exchange a little more than
two months ago on March 20th just before
the trading floor was shut down due to
the pandemic the shutdown is something
that has happened a few other times in
the past like after the 9/11 terror
attacks and after superstorm sandy with
both events trades were halted entirely
while trading continued this time
electronically the floor itself has
remained vacant that will change on
Tuesday when the exchanges physical
footprint reopens with new safety
measures in place it is a time-honored
tradition the ringing of the opening and
closing valves at the New York Stock
Exchange and while that iconic clanging
wasn't silenced by the corona virus
pandemic its home the trading floor was
there's a clarity in crisis you know
what you need to do and you knew you
don't you know when you need to do it
Stacy Cunningham is the president of the
New York Stock Exchange
who ordered the trading floor closed
March 23rd as the pandemic was unfolding
we were concerned about the health care
system and putting any additional strain
so we made the decision to while we were
learning more take a step back send
traders home so that we weren't adding
any additional strain we profiled
Cunningham two years ago as she was
taking over the helm on Wall Street
she says back then she never imagined
having to make a decision like this but
says her experience working on the
trading floor during another turbulent
time in American history came to mind
911 I was here I was working on the
trading floor you really got after that
event there's sort of a New York tough
component to that this is a little
scarier because you're worrying about
once you're in the building you're still
not entirely comfortable which is the
whole reason for the pause yes yes yes
let's take a pause
unlike 2001 and other closures this
marked the first time in the 227 year
history of the New York Stock Exchange
that trading continued electronically
while the physical floor was shut down
and it did so without a hitch so we've
prepared some of those preparations look
like pauses Marv
right circuit breakers and some of them
allow us to continue operations even if
the trading floor isn't accessible so
you always have a little bit of anxiety
as you're getting ready to see it live
for the first time but it worked
flawlessly and that's really a testament
to the teams and their preparations
about 80% of trading on the New York
Stock Exchange is done electronically
even under normal circumstances if so
much trading is already done
electronically why do you need to open
the trading great question it's the the
moments in time those moments of stress
where it matters most is where human
judgment is most valuable the traders on
the floor aren't going to stop major
market movements but they're going to
make that micro volatility this small
rounded out around the edges which saves
investors money and we have seen a
degradation since we've triply closed
the trading floor is there also a
symbolism to having the New York Stock
Exchange trading floor open without a
doubt the New York Stock Exchange facade
is the face of capitalism in our global
economy more broadly and so recognizing
the fact that we can set an example for
how America should reopen slowly
cautiously flexibly ready to move as
needed is an important thing for our
economy more broadly as we look to get
us started but the trading floor won't
look like this when it reopens Tuesday
PPE like face masks will be required
along with social distancing and there
will only be about 25 percent of the
normal trader workforce on the floor
around a hundred people we're focusing
on those that are small businesses
because they're most impacted I think
that's an important message for for New
York in the u.s. to let's let's help
those that are impacted most by this and
start with our energy there and if
others can stay remote let's keep them
at home to reduce the risk in our
communities how much have you thought
about what it will be like having that
opening bell ring on Tuesday with
traders there on the floor it's gonna be
a certainly a very historic moment and
special moment for the traders on the
floor to come back but it's not the
moment we're looking forward to
celebrating the the bell that will
really celebrate is when the u.s. gets
to open for business again and we can
really celebrate
reopening of America and you know the
one thing that I was talking to Stacey
about as they are reopening is the
question I think a lot of people have so
what happens if somebody test positive
who's there and she pointed out that
they're not looking at just stopping one
person if one person tests positive it's
about an outbreak so they're taking all
of those regular precautions the
temperature checks and the mask that we
mentioned and that's the idea behind
this that was the idea behind the pause
and they go forward hoping to keep
everyone safe great update Dana love
seeing you guys two years ago loved
loved seeing the update so we'll wait
and see what happens this week